[Music]
where do you think
you're going pewdiepie
i didn't think you would show your face
again not after last time
i have been training since then and i
have become
more powerful than you could ever
imagine hmm
you'll never obtain what you seek out of
my way
he'll never defeat me
how did he move so fast
new user slash inspired by me pewdiepie
available now at g-field.com very
excited announcement
some of you have noticed this and uh
they told me not to
leak it but there it is
i can finally show it fully the new
pewdiepie
g fuel flavor legendary moment
yuzu slash baby comes with a new shaker
which i've already leaked as well
looking hella spicy the flavor is yusuf
slash
user which is a japanese lemon tastes
like god the coconut oil
very epic tastes
even epicure you guys know i love gpu
there's no secret
i don't even know if i need to yap about
this but if you want to try out the new
flavor
use the code pewdiepie and you get 30
off
that's right baby 30 time to stock up on
g fuel enter coke pewdiepie
get the old flavor get the new one as
well get the cup
30 percent what do you do in the waiting
for it is a good deal
great flavor for the summer very
refreshing
yusu is a citrusy tart flavor
that is best described as a mashup of
grapefruit lemon
and mandarin a very taste guys a very
taste
listen i i don't buy you guys i've
always liked to drink
i like drinking more than eating almost
having a drink by your side
just make any moment better you know it
and as a guy like to drink a lot
g-fuel is actually a cheap low-calorie
energetic drink that is healthier
at least than regular energy drinks i
think can say that with confidence
okay check it out link is in the
description enter the code pewdiepie for
off okay thanks for watching video just
want to remind you again about the new
shaker
new flavor g-fuel enter the code
pewdiepie to make your order
and get 30 off that's it thanks for
watching bye
what do i have this what is that
also in this light if i turn my face
here watch this
like this unibrow normal
unibrow let's go hand so much man on the
planet let's go
[Music]
i'm back from holiday hooray great for
me being away
got a tan got a unibrow it's all good
okay this is how i react now what we saw
what might you saw except in the unibrow
it's funny because it's true i remember
taking this photo of me like this is
kind of an awkward post but it's sweet
so i'll go with it
and it turned out amazing okay no
regrets
to all the gamers who wasted time on it
oh my god that freaking ball puzzle
yeah why didn't he just place it in
honestly
it's right there goddamn tram
the stupid tram still gives me flashback
ken just hits four million
go number go he deserves it one thousand
stop it stop now yeah this is the bad
idea
of live streaming hitting uh subscriber
goals
[Applause]
ah she's wearing the same outfit as me
boys
wait charlie wore black what the is
everything okay
the universe has shifted it's tides i
see oh god i'm the same as
big ed bruh did you guys hear the leaked
the league message from big ed
i don't think he deserves his own video
but damn he crazy
we just love you but i can't be with you
are you are you done because i've been
sitting around the corner from your
house from the second i clocked out i
don't give a
liz you're up okay okay all right
so i bleeped that and also i noticed
this video is age restricted so i'm not
listening to this
my last levi got demonetized this is not
happening again listen lava 69 shakers
is it out no he used to be nice
out there oh yeah let's go we've all
been there uh-huh
okay oh man
i'm waiting early in the morning for
that merge drop
oh i swear i'm not addicted but i can't
stop
drinking hey you got amnesia man i
caught that new stuff
i got my black merch but that's not eat
13 sweatshirts now they're out of stock
i am
getting boxes all around the clock i got
big schemes of being on the big screen
so
hell yeah the big memes yeah
[Music]
he did great
you don't even own a single tambourine
yeah
you should have gone with tambourine is
it ryan's butt all right i think i'd
have
everything no i want more
no i want more cuz i got shirts
i got hoodies i got g-fuel
i got headphones i got the most merch
it's easy to see
and the people on this ready to agree
cause i buy all day
i so good i'm so
embarrassed it's so sweet i can't stop
move on hey it's all right i guess
sorry i had to cancel out for some
reason i don't know why it was great i
loved it
pewdiepie in his twenties first married
youtuber the question
uh mm-hmm uh-huh are you sure uh
brush start lifting immediately
okay very meta i like it
take control of mind and body know me
watching pewds in middle school
me watching putin college hell
yeah what is the left the right one
supposed to represent i can't
is this a wholesome meme or not i need
answers
i didn't look at that all right
i gotta give you guys props when i was
camping i didn't
my friend told me about it so one of the
campsites uh
had a bunch of young people in it and we
obviously got recognized
and i don't know we're on holiday we're
just doing our own thing
you know if people say hi obviously
that's fine but uh
my friend overheard one of the other
uh people us and she said that one of
the people started freaking out like oh
my god it's pewdiepie we have to go up
and take a photo
and the other person said no he doesn't
like that
and they just left us alone which big
huge peepee i respect that thank you
guys
respectful audience cheers to you mate
personal boundaries chiefs do you make
huh
how many how many youtubers can say that
they have an audience that do that
to be honest it is a weird thing right
it's not a big deal to take a photo
but i am so happy i made that choice
because i can tell
immediately who's an actual fan as soon
as i said no
because people that are fans are are
just cool with
it and we have a normal interaction but
the people that aren't
get kind of like
there's one guy that said what do you
say it doesn't matter it's not like i
was offended but he said
is that pewdiepie to my face and i know
it's whatever but it just confirms to me
the kind of
how people view you not as a person but
as a
as a i don't say object but more like a
something inanimate object that's no i
don't know what the i'm trying to
say
it just confirmed to me that people some
people kind of watch at
youtubers and celebrities or whatever
you want to call it as
some sort of token like oh that is a
pewdiepie in the wild have to take photo
right
this is weird i don't get it but i
really respect you guys for
doing that uh anyway
[Laughter]
i have gray shirts okay sometimes tsuki
baby can you tell on them
can you tell that's a marketing right
there
so i sent all my clothes to japan and
that's why i just started wearing the
shirts that i had
but now i really like it comfortable
every single day baby
except if it's really hot outside black
shirt is a bad idea if it's hot and
sunny
but then again white shirt bad idea if
eating pasta
and with an italian wife the choice is
obvious
i'm not a typical swedish guy but i put
sweden on the map
he's not wrong if i ever say i'm from
sweden to a stranger
and they don't know who i am they're
like oh slothan like slothan right yeah
just like we're all like him a whole
country of south towns over here we're
just
it's all certain girls with time machine
i am your granddaddy
really wait wait
oh thank god he brought the bday hell
yeah
thank you arnold this could have all
been prevented
i take back every nice thing i said you
could have stopped it
whoa whoa whoa okay big pee pee made it
a meanie i can't tower out a pipe
pi oh that's what it is what you
hell yeah never expected to see this
when i built it
don't worry felix we got you naruto
the greatest anime i love naruto
wait there's guns in naruto hell yeah oh
my sister sent this mean
everyone attack on titan isn't real it
can't hurt you
one swedish family
nice be by stan page keep up the memes
guys
my family loves it i would like to say
thanks to the person that
taught me english i taught you english
well you're welcome for your broken
english because i can't speak it still
stupid british language makes no sense
hey that's amazing
damn the details
how many hours this took they didn't
post how many hours it took then what's
the
pulling still huge peepee well done mr
golden life very nice
finally you guys are picking up just how
worthless
and dumb i'm kidding i love you wherever
you are i don't care
useless probably away doing some useless
things big course spending millions to
gain subscribers
look what they need to mimic a fraction
of our power
hell yeah those fools we receive
meme review with critical you receive no
more poop and shower memes that's fair i
thought he didn't like memes
when you share a funny story on the
internet and your fanbase starts to
bully you
amazing and no i didn't in the
shower of any of the campsites
and you know what seeing how the showers
were at the campsite maybe i should have
in the
shower huh everything goodnight
you can't stop me uh apparently there's
some
issue with outer minds text uh
purchase support i'll tell them about it
okay i'm sure this is just a mistake
outerminds legitimately most honest
open and kind people i've ever worked
with
there's no doubt in my mind that we'll
fix this okay but yeah sorry about the
inconvenience
i guess i'm tech support now is that
naruto
he loves naruto i don't get it
sake there's no way i thought i
thought going on a holiday
would make this stop it never stops
okay how about this so people use the
same face for their
thumbnails as a way to market themselves
i'm gonna give you guys
that's right i'm giving you guys the
choice top
upvoted face phase of me becomes the new
thumbnail
nail template go internet do your thing
petition to add a shower theme
environment so poofty can poop there oh
my god why did we not think of this
poop these chapter two out now by the
way gonna live stream it
check it out link is in the description
also a lovely team of damps
i like to thank psy for these edit frogs
i'd like to thank scythe too thank you
sam
that's a good meme bro they they're
still patching it and it's still broken
as hell
there it is what the hell you're trying
to rip off my style critical
uncalled for bro that's sick i have it
i painted it i just haven't assembled it
i'll do it it's coming
i know everyone is waiting that looks
amazing 10 out of 10.
why gundam wear a jacket i don't know
maybe he cold
[Music]
okay all right
i don't think this is intentional
pewdiepie theme no no way
i feel like this type of car is like
yeah i can tell it's expensive but
it doesn't look good not even the
pewdiepie skin can save it bro
oh my god
same energy right there cute just like i
remember that day
it was so perfect i wouldn't have
changed the thing oh wait
that's what i would change now it's
perfect
pewdiepie is featured in a dormant video
but in a negative way
a lot of people and i assume you know
who pewdiepie is oh
yeah he's like one of the biggest
channels in youtube and he pretty much
just made a video blasting me
i'm super excited i already hate it
doesn't make any sense i didn't think it
would annoy me so much
keep changing a way to cut out all the
context i hate it
that's crazy why would he do that i
don't know because it's cringe bro i
don't know
why would he do that someone stop him
stop him it was just for fun
listen it was a bad video i stand by
that
even if you try to do a positive message
which is great
go ahead i ain't gonna stop you it was
delivered so poorly but
there's no way you could understand it
and if anything it just misconstrued it
i don't think just because you're trying
to do something good you're above uh
criticism but it seemed like darmian
took it with stride until i saw this so
i don't i don't know i don't really care
i i just know i i have no actual ill ill
blood
or anything i don't think he has either
not trying to cause tea here
he's doing his thing i'm doing my thing
this is it choose a side
the fate of the world depends on it giga
chat or ricardo choose wisely what the
is this cringe
gigachat obviously today i turned 20.
thank you nine-year-olds it's been a
pleasure serving with you
a moment of silence there it is
all right i think that's enough memes
thank you fill in a wholesome mode so
thank you guys
that's it thanks thanks a lot i mean it
thank you
thank you can i say a genuine thank you
thank you bye